En este vídeo quiero atacar algunas desigualdades
que involucran multiplicar y dividir
por números positivos y negativos
y verás que es un poco más truculento
que solo sumar y restar números
que vimos, por ejemplo en el último vídeo,
y también quiero introducirte
a otro tipo de notaciones
para describir el conjunto solución
de una desigualdad,
así que hagamos un par de ejemplos.
Por ejemplo,
que tenemos la desigualdad menos
déjenme...
déjenme corregirlo, -0.5x
¿Ok? Y que esto sea
menor o igual que 7.5
Ok,
tenemos esta desigualdad de aquí
¿y cómo lo resolvemos?
Bueno si fuera una igualdad,
¿qué es lo que es lo que se nos antojaría hacer?
Bueno, pues multiplicar por...
o más bien dividir entre -0.5 ¿verdad?
de tal suerte que del lado izquierdo
quitamos el coeficiente
y del lado derecho ya nos queda un número ¿verdad?
Sin embargo en las desigualdades
no es tan inmediato...
no es tan inmediato, de hecho cuando
multiplicamos o dividimos por un número negativo,
lo que tenemos que hacer es
cambiar el signo de la desigualdad,
debemos invertir ese orden,
y les voy a dar un ejemplito de
porqué esto es cierto.
Por ejemplo todo el mundo estará de acuerdo
que el número 1 es más chico
que el número 2
Eso, eso yo creo que nadie
lo va a dudar en estos momentos,
sin embargo,
¿qué pasaría si nosotros multiplicamos por -1?
Entonces aquí me quedaría -1
y del otro lado me quedaría -2
yo te preguntaría,
¿qué número es más chico?
Bueno, pues queda claro que el -2 es más negativo
que -1 ¿verdad?
Entonces este número es más pequeño,
entonces como puedes darte cuenta,
si un número es más grande que el otro,
entonces al multiplicarlo por -1
lo que está haciendo es volverlo más negativo, ¿verdad?
quiere decir que se está volviendo
mucho más pequeño en el sentido de que se vuelve más negativo,
y aquí por supuesto
no es una demostración
de porqué al multiplicar por un número negativo,
hay que invertir el orden de la desigualdad
sin embargo,
yo creo que con esto te sentirás más cómodo, ¿verdad?
Así que,
lo que tenemos que hacer aquí es
dividir entre - 0.5
ó multiplicar por algún número
que sea negativo y así,
se invierte la desigualdad,
y bueno,
¿cuál es el número por el que
hay que multiplicar o dividir?
Bueno en realidad si nosotros multiplicamos
esta desigualdad por - 2
ya lo logramos ¿verdad?
Y es que en realidad estoy pensando el 0.5,
que es la mitad de 5, ¿verdad?
entonces esto es como -1/2,
¿cómo cancelo -1/2?
Pues con -2 así que,
de ambos lados
multiplicamos por -2,
de este lado se quedaría
multiplicado por -0.5x,
ahorita checamos la desigualdad
y aquí nos quedaría 7.5 multiplicado por -2.
Y la desigualdad dijimos
que se cambia en este tipo de casos,
así que en vez
de ser menor o igual
va a ser mayor o igual.
Entonces vamos a resolver esto,
¿de dónde salió el -2?
Insisto de que el -0.5 es como - 1/2
Entonces -2 por -0.5 es 2 veces 0.5
que es 1 ¿verdad?
Entonces tenemos simplemente
"x" es mayor o igual que -2 por 7.5,
que es -2 por 7.5, es 15
Entonces mi solución es
todos los números que sean
más grandes o iguales que -15 ¿verdad?
Incluso tú puedes aquí
intentar poner el 0
que claramente el 0 es más grande
que cualquier número negativo en particular el -15,
o por ejemplo puedes intentar el
el -16
¿verdad?
si tú pones -16,
eso no es cierto que sea mayor o igual que -15,
de hecho si tú pones -16 aquí
serían menos por menos, más
0.5 por 16
ó la mitad de 16 es 8,
que claramente
no es menor o igual que 7.5 ¿verdad?
Entonces si nosotros
fuéramos a dibujar esta solución,
el conjunto solución,
podríamos pintar una recta real,
una recta de números reales
y digamos que por acá anda el -15,
por acá andará el -16,
¿verdad?
Seguimos del lado izquierdo
y del derecho
y acá tendremos el -14.
Entonces,
¿cómo graficamos nuestra solución?
Primero el -15 sí lo incluimos
y además nos tomamos
todos los que están a la derecha de él, ¿verdad?
todos los que son mayores o iguales,
entonces,
así es como se vería graficado
pero,
quizás también has visto
esto como un conjunto solución,
en términos de un intervalo
¿Qué significaría esto?
Bueno ponemos el -15
y como vamos a incluirlo le ponemos un
corchete... sí....
uno de estos paréntesis rectangulares,
me parece que son los corchetes ¿verdad?
Entonces
le ponemos un corchete,
siempre que queramos incluir este número,
y nos vamos a ir
hacia adelante hasta el infinito.
Entonces,
aquí le vamos a poner el paréntesis
normal
y esto es generalmente
cuando ponemos este tipo de paréntesis,
es porque no estamos incluyendo
este número de aquí,
y en realidad el infinito no lo vamos a incluir,
el infinito no es un número, ¿verdad?
No es como que uno puede decir,
"¡Ah claro, ya llegué al infinito!"
Nunca vamos a llegar al infinito,
así es que en general pues el paréntesis
se ocupa para cuando no incluimos el punto
o para cuando estemos trabajando con infinito.
Y quizás también lo habrás visto de esta forma, con...
abriendo una llave en términos,
o en notación conjuntista
¿verdad?
Esto es el conjunto de todos los "x"
"x" es un número real...
un número...
número real
tal que...
y se pone con una barrita así,
tal que "x"
es mayor o igual que -15.
Y esto también
es una forma de expresar lo mismo,
esto, esto, esto y esto es bueno,
la forma gráfica.
Estas son formas equivalentes de ver la solución,
el conjunto solución.
Vamos a hacer otro ejemplo...
Vamos a hacer otro ejemplo,
digamos este
75x
es mayor o igual que 125
En este caso,
ya no vamos a necesitar
multiplicar por números negativos,
así que,
en realidad lo que yo puedo hacer es
dividir de ambos lados sobre 75,
dividimos sobre 75 y no hay que cambiar la desigualdad,
porque este no fue negativo,
recuerda que solo hay que cambiarlo
cuando es negativo.
Entonces,
¿qué es lo que me queda?
Aquí nos queda "x"
es mayor o igual que 125
sobre
75,
y bueno ya esta sería la solución,
pero si queremos simplificarlo
podemos dividir en el numerador
y en el denominador
por me parece 25,
porque esto es 5 veces 25
entonces me queda 5
y abajo esto es 25 por 3
¿verdad?
entonces me queda 3.
El conjunto solución,
son los números mayores o iguales que 5/3,
entonces,
si lo expresamos en términos de intervalos
pues tenemos al 5/3
y le ponemos este...
este corchete porque sí lo estamos incluyendo
¿verdad?
Y nos seguimos todo derecho hasta el infinito
y éste no lo incluimos porque ni siquiera es un número
¿Cómo lo graficamos?
Ponemos nuevamente nuestra recta real
y ubicamos el 5/3,
que más o menos es 1 y 2/3
entonces por acá andará el 0,
por aquí andara el 1,
por aquí andara el 2,
y este es 1 con 2/3,
así que anda por aquí,
este es el 5/3...
y lo que hacemos es tomarnos todos
desde el 5/3 en adelante ¿verdad?
nos los tomamos todos
todos estos
y éste lo incluimos
Vamos con otro ejemplo más,
por ejemplo que tenemos el "x" sobre -3
mayor que -10/9
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer aquí,
este "x" entre -3,
lo podemos pensar
como -1/3 de "x"...
entonces esto es -1/3 de "x"
Y para cancelar esto pues necesariamente
tenemos que multiplicar por -3 ¿verdad?
Tenemos que multiplicar por -3,
los signos se cancelan
y 3 sobre 3 nos da 1
y a ver, del otro lado,
tenemos que multiplicar exactamente por lo mismo
por
-3
Ahora ¿Cómo multiplicamos por un número negativo? ¿Qué dijimos?
Que el signo de la desigualdad
tiene que cambiar de orientación,
entonces, en vez de ser mayor que
ahora va a ser un menor que,
¿Cómo nos quedaría finalmente?
Esto se cancela y me queda "x"
es menor que -10/9 por -3
los signos se cancelan
y me queda,
por ejemplo,
podemos cancelar aquí el 3
¿no?
y cancelar aquí un 3
y me queda 3
y me queda efectivamente 10/3
¿verdad?
los signos se cancelan
entonces me queda
"x" menor que 10/3
y si queremos expresarlo
en términos de conjuntos pues,
vamos a tomarnos el 10/3,
éste no lo vamos a incluir ¿verdad?
no viene el igual, así que le ponemos
este límite de paréntesis
y vamos a ir bajando, bajando, bajando
hasta menos infinito
y como menos infinito no es un número
le ponemos su paréntesis normal
¿verdad?
¿Cómo se grafica?
Nuevamente...
tenemos nuestra recta...
No sé, por ejemplo,
10/3 son como 3, 1/3
entonces por aquí andará
el 0, el 1, el 2, el 3, y el 4
y estos son 3 enteros 1/3,
entonces, más o menos va a andar por acá,
por aquí andará el 10,
el 10/3
y éste no lo incluimos,
por eso dejamos la bolita abierta
y nos tomamos todos a la izquierda,
todos a la izquierda...
Así se grafica mi solución.
Vamos a hacer un último ejemplo...
vamos a hacer un último ejemplo,
apartado de lo que ya hemos hecho,
por ejemplo
"x" sobre -15 es menor que 8,
Entonces misma, misma técnica,
¿cómo quitamos al -15?
pues multiplicando
por -15 de ambos lados,
aquí multiplica a "x" sobre -15
y del otro lado me queda 8 por -15
y nuevamente como como esto fue multiplicar
por un número negativo,
la desigualdad cambia de orientación.
Entonces ahora es un mayor que,
esto se cancela,
tenemos "x" mayor que 8 por -15
y 8 por -15 es
8 por 5...
5 por 8 son 40,
llevo 4,
8 por 1 son 8 y 4 son 12
entonces es 120
y con este menos ahí se lo dejamos
entonces ¿cuál es...?
¿Cómo se ve en términos de intervalo?
Pues empezamos en -120
no lo incluimos,
así que le ponemos este paréntesis
y nos seguimos
derechito hasta el infinito...
O bien,
si lo queremos graficar,
tenemos esta recta
¿verdad?
aquí a lo mejor andará el -120
quizá sacando el 0
y nos tomamos..
bueno,
más bien el -120 no lo tomamos
y nos vamos hacia la derecha
¿verdad?
Entonces puedes intentar algunos números,
por ejemplo el 0,
el 0 funciona,
pues sí claro,
0 entre -15 es 0,
que claramente es menor que 8,
y aunque eso no demuestra nada
puedes intentar cualquiera de estos números
que se encuentren de este lado y deben funcionar.
Así que espero
que esto te haya resultado bastante útil.
Nos vemos en el próximo vídeo.